the past casts a long shadow in Northern
Ireland
[Applause]
these Irish Republicans weren't cheering
The Good Friday agreement but Marching
In opposition to it and their refusal to
condemn the use of violence leads to the
inevitable
youths attacking police in Londonderry
this is exactly the tactic security
Chiefs had feared that young people
would be incited to engage in civil
disorder to attract officers into this
area where they become vulnerable to
terrorist attack
it was a sporadic incident but the
threat of something more serious remains
with dissident Republicans publicly
encouraging armed conflict in pursuit of
Irish Unity
so long as you continue to oppress us
you will meet with the inescapable
consequences
historically oppression breed resistance
so I couldn't
it isn't enough the shape up the ARA the
important thing is to join
but former Shin fan leader Jerry Adams
who persuaded the provisional Ira to
call a ceasefire says the Good Friday
agreement gave armed groups an
alternative we knew the agreement wasn't
the end the agreement was the beginning
of a new Journey
uh but but at least we had a mechanism
for people to have their say uh which
then allowed us to argue that there was
that there was no need for armed actions
or no need for violence that this was
the the way to go forward
there will be a major Security operation
for President Biden's visit the lack of
a power sharing government at Stormont
contributing to a dangerous political
vacuum here 25 years ago the commitment
was from the parties to resolve
differences through Democratic and
peaceful means and that's the only
alternative to the use of political
violence and this is why in the face of
the apparent rise in the in the
Terror threat that the institutions
remain fundamentally important and that
means of democratic expression remains
just as important today as as ever
before
if Rishi sunak needs reminding that
pieces on finished business it's the
Sinister image of masked man and women
glorifying terrorism with an illegal
parade David Blevins Sky News in Derry